[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas han pasado más de dos
semanas desde los devastadores
terremotos de Siria y Turquía a la fecha
de grabación de este programa se
contaban más de 47.000 muertos en ambos
países y las tareas de rescate ya
llegaban a su fin nuestros compañeros de
France 24 en inglés visitaron una ciudad
Siria cercana al epicentro del sismo que
antes de la tragedia acogida a
refugiados de la guerra civil de ese
país muchos de Ellos son niños
días después del terremoto los
socorristas continúan sacando cuerpos de
los escombros cerca del epicentro de la
tragedia Hay una ciudad que acogía a
miles de refugiados sirios incluyendo
niños que ya han vivido mucho durante la
Guerra y para quienes el trauma Es
evidente
Mohamed de 12 años es de jama en el
centro de Siria y nos lleva a conocer a
su familia sobrevivieron al terremoto
pero su casa ha quedado gravemente
afectada Aunque no es seguro no tiene
nada de ir
tengo miedo tengo miedo cada vez que voy
a mi habitación creo que se moverá caerá
y luego hará mucho ruido no soy solo yo
quien tiene miedo mis hermanos también
mi hermana tiene demasiado miedo para
entrar en nuestra casa el techo está
roto y eso también nos asusta
esos niños nunca han conocido un momento
sin guerra en Siria y ahora la madre
naturaleza ha atacado el lugar que
habían apropiado como su hogar su
Refugio seguro se ha desplomado en una
noche
el día después del terremoto los niños
estaban luchando psicológicamente pero
se han visto obligados a adaptarse
debido a la guerra en Siria
cada vez que salen también otro
terremoto o una bomba lanzada por bachar
al azar
con millones de necesitados aquí
la situación de seguridad es angustiante
los saqueos son cada vez más comunes y
algunos culpan a los refugiados sirios
la policía nos trató mal yo estaba
tratando de llevar un poco de madera
para calentar a mi familia y me hicieron
tirarla me acusaron de ser un ladrón soy
un ladrón con esta mano herida estaba
ayudando a los turcos me quedé dos días
para ayudarlos mi hijo y yo
Esta es una región donde las comunidades
han coexistido durante siglos pero
incluso antes del terremoto existían
tensiones entre turcos y sirios ahora
para familias como estas hay preguntas
reales sobre qué les depara el futuro
fachadas de banco quemadas vidrios rotos
y gritos de desesperación en las calles
escenas como estas se vivieron
recientemente en beirut la capital del
Líbano en ese país sumido en una
profunda crisis económica las entidades
bancarias han impuesto serias
restricciones al retiro de fondos los
ciudadanos han intentado recuperar su
propio dinero a través de acciones
legales pero también por la fuerza con
salarios de menos de 100 dólares al mes
los policías municipales y nacionales se
han convertido en los funcionarios peor
pagados del país esto ha llevado a que
muchos de ellos abandonen sus puestos de
trabajo para intentar ganar dinero en
otra parte dejando sin protección a
miles de ciudadanos que están al acecho
de la delincuencia el informe es de
nuestra corresponsal etel
tonios Policía Municipal desde hace 22
años pero para poder pagar sus facturas
ha recurrido a su viejo maletín de
peluquería para nuevamente hacer cortes
de pelo a domicilio
dijiste oficio porque creí que ser
funcionario era más seguro con una
seguridad social y jubilación ahora con
lo que me pagan no es suficiente para
cubrir los gastos mínimos de mi familia
así que hago esto en mis días libres
el municipio de Villa es la tercera
ciudad más grande del Líbano pero de la
seguridad se encargan solo tonies
compañero asi Quién es el más veterano y
una decena de agentes locales somos dos
oficiales fijos y cubrimos todo el área
hacemos de todo y nuestros salarios son
extremadamente bajos como funcionario
público no se me permite aplicar para
otro trabajo de esta alcaldía depende de
los pueblos vecinos pero los recortes y
la normativa que impide nuevo
reclutamiento este funcionarios públicos
desde 2019 los deja desprovistos de la
seguridad la municipalidad de Davis
sigue haciendo todo lo posible en estos
tiempos difíciles Aunque tengamos que
asumir otras responsabilidades por falta
de personal El colapso Financiero
agudiza las tensiones sociales que
aumenta la criminalidad para ello tomaba
altas Apuesta por mejorar la
capacitación de estos agentes y
garantizar su sostenibilidad como
objetivos del programa europeo de
policía proximidad del que es miembro
hay una palabra muy bonita en inglés
público Walker que significa que toda
persona que trabaja en un organismo
encargado de hacer cumplir la ley está
al servicio de los ciudadanos para poder
ofrecer el mejor servicio a los
ciudadanos las agencias de seguridad
deben cooperar entre sí sin embargo las
diferencias hectáreas del carácter
oligárquico del sistema libanés
dificultan las colaboraciones entre la
policía los consejos municipales y la
sociedad civil este espacio de discusión
contribuye a mejorar la percepción mutua
en Venezuela el gremio de maestros
cumple más de 40 días de protestas para
exigir un salario digno que esté acorde
con el costo de la canasta básica en el
último año el salario mínimo en
Venezuela pasó el más bajo de América
Latina en promedio los maestros del
sector público ganan entre 6 y 20
dólares al mes Daniela Zambrano nos
amplía la noticia desde Caracas Sandra
alayas licenciada en educación con
posgrado y ejerce desde hace 15 años la
docencia su sueldo no llega a los 20
dólares mensuales en un país en el que
la canasta básica ronda los 500 para
obtener más dinero da clases
particulares a unos 20 niños en esta
escuela improvisada nosotros estudiamos
para tener una mejor calidad de vida una
profesión
este mejor preparado Pero ahora vender
helado costura peluquería es lo que
realmente le daría a un docente para
cubrir algunas necesidades no todas
desde el pasado 9 de enero Sandra se ha
unido a las protestas de calle para
exigir un salario digno no tiene miedo a
ser despedida dice no tener Nada que
perder Cómo enseñamos si no tenemos
pasajes no tenemos a vestuario no
tenemos Zapatos o sea nada nos cubre ya
por Venezuela al frente de las protestas
de educadores del sector público ha
estado Elsa Castillo una dirigente
sindical con 30 años de servicio pese a
sufrir asedio y persecución ha recorrido
todo el país juntando fuerzas para
continuar la protesta el evento más más
duro fue cuando nos bajaron de un carro
que es solo denuncié en su oportunidad
en agosto cuando nos bajaron de un carro
a punta de pistola y nos hicieron
amenazas
el último año el Bolívar pasó de 5 a 25
bolívares por dólar y el salario de los
trabajadores se convirtió en el más bajo
de América Latina incluso por debajo de
Haití Honduras y Cuba pero según este
economista indexar el sueldo mínimo a la
canasta básica como piden los maestros
no es factible la única manera de que el
salario real se incremente de manera
sostenibles que hay aumentos de
productividad Y que además logres
controlar la inflación mientras tengas
infracciones de 440 por ciento No hay
manera que los aumentos salariales sean
por encima de la inflación en medio de
las masivas protestas la asamblea
nacional aprobó una ley que permitiría
bachilleres ejercer como docentes en
sustitución de los maestros
Sandra no está de acuerdo con la medida
como tampoco lo está contener que
regresar a casa caminando porque el
dinero no le alcanza para el transporte
y con el carnaval el color y la alegría
volvieron a las calles de Río de Janeiro
tras dos años de restricciones
pandémicas así volvieron también a las
calles las comparsas carnavalescas
conocidas como blocos el año pasado solo
fueron autorizados los desfiles de las
escuelas de samba Aunque algunos locos
salieron a pesar de las reglas
sanitarias este año 456 comparsas
autorizadas animaron la fiesta más
conocida de Brasil el ayuntamiento
Calcula que el carnaval mueve alrededor
de 864 millones de dólares y nuestros
corresponsales acompañaron el boitatá
uno de los bloques más populares de la
ciudad
[Música]
la fanfarria los tambores de rochan
Alegría en el centro de Río de Janeiro y
eso a pesar de que son las 7 de la
mañana la calle está repleta de personas
disfrazadas de todas las edades
hay mucha pasión por la fiesta por el
carnaval creo que nacemos con ella y
esta comparsa es la cosa más linda que
hay en Río de Janeiro
se llama cordón del boitatá y está
inspirado en un personaje del folklore
brasileño es una serpiente de fuego que
protege a los animales y a los bosques
de los que quieren destruirlos es algo
muy actual en Brasil
los cariocas son famosos por su ironía a
la hora de crear los disfraces
hasta que descubrió Shakira descubrió la
tradición de Piqué porque su tarro de
mermelada estaba más vacío y a Piqué y a
sus hijos no les gustaba la mermelada
Entonces se dio cuenta de que alguien
estaba comiendo su mermelada cada año
creo un disfraz nuevo el disfraz tiene
que estar ligado a la actualidad Y ser
divertido
la sátira política es algo intrínseco al
carnaval de Río de Janeiro y la
referencia a los ataques de Brasilia no
podía faltar
a tus padres
yo represento a Los Patriotas que se
quedaron acampados durante 60 días
esperando en realidad una intervención
alcohólica ellos no esperaban una
intervención militar es por eso que
nuestro lema es Carnaval encima de todo
y cachaza dentro de todos
cucharaditas de plástico y otros objetos
cotidianos se transforman en trajes
originales y hasta musicales el carnaval
aquí no es solo diversión es también
creatividad tradición y sensualidad
queremos agradecer al restaurante la
herencia por permitirnos grabar nuestro
programa en sus instalaciones y a
ustedes también Muchas gracias por
seguir una nueva emisión de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
francés 24 y France 24.com